yes and I feel like I honestly
everything on my body feels sticky yes
true thank you for my ninja look to the
Halloween edition of a Holy Trinity
video a holy turn you were saying you're
a poor man and that's my way I've tried
to get around actually having a title
for this video that's why this is my
sassy werewolf
very rare for next the night that we are
shooting my drug pumpkin and last year
you know that before we shot my drug
pumpkin we shot a video on my channel
about creating a Halloween costumes
based off of random ingredients items
yet items objects I am a garbage bag
monster with the toilet paper baby that
has touched soup for your everyday days
create stores I do it aa this year we've
tried to organize it a little bit more I
really wanted to feel like chopped so we
have Diane Kang they enjoy yourself
oh she's hideous oh oh you're doing
three rounds of Halloween costume making
we have three mystery ingredients in our
boxes this is the nicest thing I've ever
owned
oh the mystery casket I'm miss cuts on
chopped it's open your mystery baskets
with mystery casket
so you guys are going to vote in the
comments section below after each round
and let us know who made the best
costume we're gonna have two minutes
once we open our missionary canyons to
create a costume Diane has a stopwatch
going going you get to Nationals
I don't always time we have a lot of
drunk pumpkin demon king king to do oh I
don't want to waste time trying to
annunciate no I love a good milk
chocolate colored ribbons
mamrie however is great everybody does
oh by the way just like on chopped
there's a pantry of ingredients that you
are allowed to use in your dishes that
aren't part of the mystery box and here
we have our costume pantry which
includes scissors sharpies and tape that
we can use at any moment to create any
part of our own costumes is the pantry
this is a I'm Great Depression can you
tell us more about the ramen crushing
hello our ingredients are oh my god two
minutes to make across o95
County on the back and Alberto can I ask
you this too we did know and we're
attended two minutes I said fine if you
want okay
we have one more minute
ten seconds nine eight wait longer
heaven six five four three two one
hello alright you can't use the phone so
he says you can please have a can't no
no problem I'll start this off okay
don't have that much confidence in my
own my custom is home Oh Lilian a dick
very polarizing I'm sorry
I appreciate the creativity that all of
you have the room next anyone I'll go
okay I'm a Mac saccade posture I am a
garbage bag monster with a toilet paper
baby my face is the rainbow colored
pubic hair
oh three judges spell my weapons the
different colors represent different
weapons that come shooting out of my Mac
Spanish hey come on we supposed to go
for the like fools batsh crazy backstory
everything is about backstory to me I
really like to dive deep right there ah
okay well I'm clearly a businesswoman
from the 80s I'm calling for a working
girl anything I have the bags I have the
shoulder pad Hey
and I have the people here to call this
looks Melanie Griffith Oh
working her yeah you're gonna have to
google that an extremely difficult
decision but we're going to ask you the
comments below to let us know who you
think won round one we are going to move
on to round two Diana's on to place new
costume potential in all of our mystery
caskets yes who would wear a pad for
eight hours
hello oh my god it'll be a party my gosh
oh and we have very colorful paper
Oh have two ish minutes to get this Cup
oh my god
much younger your left
I don't know I hear I didn't have time
I'm T we have no second son oh this is
don't think by giving us more time
except well you might need
thirty seconds seven six five maybe six
men to 33 why hello
I guess I'll go first again guard and a
Peschel nobody commuted normal but very
pensive about your boy oh my god yeah
live in hearing it for 40 years
okay I'm a party foul of it
I'm a unicorn oh so with my grass my
corn and then my big black sucks when
she got crotchety my alarm stops whoo
too hot
oh my god honestly thing with this name
and this look you can release an EP and
go number one good too hot that's your
EP never if he is are you guys out here
and put this mask on it sounds crazy
yeah no thing yeah I'm good are you
trying to get us to put that on but her
plan was foiled hey come and do one
round - hello hey it can't be paper hood
monster this you got coming
I'm just try and get down there
okay I'll go first
I am cliffie from Microsoft Word I'm a
warrior pregnant lady with a statement
necklace and as weird cravings
oh so you're Kim Zolciak they're an
actual monster it's like it's on my bed
and then I just felt the bullet silly
straight cuz I thought that'd be cool I
was going for a Dolly Parton thing
obviously but then I switched gears and
I'm silly Ray Cyrus and I'm playing with
the silly string quartet what's a bigger
foot
whadya boobs on your shoulder because
that's my mullet well everybody uh this
is a great warm-up because make a few
more videos of you guys shooting tonight
on both Hannah and memories channel let
us know in the comments below who you
think actually won this Halloween
costume version of chopped and if you're
at home by yourself give yourself a solo
round of applause for Diane came
together shop today captain is giving us
the reward which is Oh
make sure after you watch this video you
go watch I'm a memories video or Hanna's
video and it's just you know here we go
Oh going to say I don't know yeah I
don't know ah the two of you from this
angle but we've been through a lot
brilliant shoulder pads though what
explains the bubble wrap around the neck
they just wave a really big bows around
their neck baby's crying for a female in
the workforce in the 80s you really got
to protect your neck Oh break that glass
ceiling with your head here Dan can you
hit that last one on the floor right
there that one's not done that's all
that's got 100 percent off cool it's
chicken